wano is officially over the straw hats
are moving on to the next island sailing
towards the south east of wano karibu
has gotten his hands on the location of
another ancient weapon and yamato is
ready to leave wano and become a pirate
in proper odin fashion oh yeah and i
almost forgot freaking buggy has
apparently somehow managed to get not
only sir crocodile under his mantle but
even mihawk which i feel exactly the
same way about as zorro does in this
chapter as well so let's talk about this
one first shall we now in what universe
exactly does someone like dracul mihawk
listen to the commands of anyone much
less someone like buggy the freaking
clown this really seems like something
that should be on the top 10 list of
things that will never ever ever happen
in one piece and yet
here we are emperor of the sea buggy the
clown has created an organization called
cross guilds which is a really cool name
i have to shamelessly admit that this
organization seems to be the next
evolutionary step of buggy's delivery
service only that this one actually
looks like something you should take
seriously we do know from the war that
crocodile is very far from being a joke
even though he lost to luffy when he was
admittedly still quite weak we know that
this man went for whitebeard's head and
fought with admirals during the war at
marineford in other words he clearly
didn't just become a warlord of the sea
by accident unlike buggy and of course
some people will gladly tell you that
having mihawk on your team basically
automatically makes you a yonko anyways
given his reputation and legendary duels
with shanks now i personally am still
very skeptical if mihawk could
legitimately defeat any of the former
yonko but he's without any doubt at
least very close to that level i think
we all can agree to at least that he's
more powerful than someone like king or
katakuri and who knows maybe he is
actually in that top tier we'll just
have to actually see him fight seriously
in order to find out but even if mihawk
is a yonko level dude in disguise then
it makes it even less likely or sensical
why he'd ever agree to work under
someone like buggy now if you're like me
just thinking about these epic battles
might get you all riled up and excited
to see some real action luckily this is
where the sponsor of today's video comes
in cross summoner r cross summoner r is
an upcoming mobile gotcha rpg with a
huge cast of fantastic characters to
collect each of which has its very own
unique backstory that you can uncover
with all the characters that you unlock
you can then build your very own party
of fighters and send them out into
battle across a variety of game modes
both pve and pvp your characters can be
trained and leveled and equipped with
new gear skills and much much more and
you can even create powerful guilds
together with your friends so make sure
to use the gift code summoner 10 that
gives you 10 free drawings right from
the start now you could of course argue
that nihawk and crocodile simply agreed
to buggy being the boss officially to
keep a low profile well knowing that
buggy is really a frauds but even in
chaotic times like these mihawk and
crocodile are both way too proud and
care about their honor to let something
like that happen but as if this
strangely powerful alliance wasn't
enough by itself however the cross guild
has also played the ultimate unor
reverse plus two plus four card on the
world government and in an absolutely
chad-like move started putting bounties
on the heads of marines now this is some
big brave move right there from the man
with the strangely large hat this way
top marines all across the world will
suddenly have to worry about being
attacked themselves by citizens or
pirates or bounty hunters there's now a
real incentive for people to come after
them just like pirates can never be sure
who's watching them and what place is or
is not safe this is an enormous shift in
the power dynamics of the worlds with
countries all over the planet in uproar
and open rebellion against the
government this is a really big deal it
also strangely enough plays a lot into
the hands of the revolutionaries though
i wonder if that was actually on purpose
or not i'm very curious if it was the
alliance with crocodile and mihawk or
the bounties that ultimately made the
government declare buggy as an emperor
probably both but i still feel like even
more must have happened to really
justify that and so the really big
question now is of course once again is
bucky simply the luckiest man alive that
is the embodiment of fake it till you
make it because oda sensei is doing a
fantastic job selling the idea that
buggy is some sort of one piece eisen
that has kept his true powers and
tensions hidden only to strike when the
time feels right i have discussed this
option in depth in this video on buggy
after it was revealed that he joined the
yonko i think both options are equally
awesome and so it really comes down to
what way oda sensei wants to take this
in is buggy the fraud that we know him
to be that simply failed his way all the
way up to the top a fun character that
just has to play some role in helping
luffy become pirate king probably
against his will who then ended up on
love tale by pure chance or is buggy the
lurking legend someone who was trained
under the former pirate king who other
than shanks has decided to lay low and
bite his time i will say that buggy
looks very much like the real deal in
this poster here so i really can't wait
to find out which of these two truths it
is and even though i've mostly talked
about mihawk here i am so pumped that
crocodile is part of this as well no
matter if crocomom is true or not in
case you don't know that's the theory
that crocodile is actually luffy's mom
you can check out my video about that
one later if you want he is an awesome
character that for some reason decided
to defend luffy at marineford and so i
really can't wait to see these two
reunited once again as well and then of
course we also have to talk about
leaving wano in the end while i still
wish that we could have spent some more
time wrapping everything up and saying
goodbye to all the wonderful characters
that we spent four entire years with i
personally am leaving wano with nothing
but immensely positive emotions really
it genuinely was my favorite arc and
island of one piece so far and i'm
already working on a full analysis of
the entire arc so make sure to subscribe
if you don't want to miss that it's
actually free to subscribe you know
now the thing that i was actually most
excited about this chapter is yamato at
the end standing on top of the palace
ready to join luffy and co i was
actually a bit confused at first why
she's still there and why the straw hats
were getting ready to leave without her
but i guess oda sensei just wanted to
give yamato that classic odin moment of
running towards the sea and finally
leaving wano to become a pirate so
hopefully hopefully fingers crossed uh
we're gonna see her on board of the
thousand sunny in the next chapter god
yamato is awesome i actually do have a
bit of a declaration to make i do think
at this point it's pretty fair to say
that yamato is my favorite character in
one piece dethroning zarro to a close
second i don't know why but i just
really vibe with yamato in so many ways
but this is also the time to say goodbye
to a bunch of other characters at least
for now all the scabbards especially of
course kinemon momonosuke who we already
know will return to play a very
important role later on in the story i
also love that sukiyaki by the way
revealed himself to mom and yori in the
end so they actually do have some true
guidance on how to run the country with
their grandfather plus of course we do
get one last awesome kinemon meme carrot
who i never really saw becoming a straw
hat honestly but who i genuinely loved
as a character nonetheless who has now
been tasked with the ridiculous
responsibility to rule over the entire
mink kingdom which you know seems like a
very strange and cruel decision in a way
the two experienced and elder leaders
chill in wanna with their buddies and
tell the little bunny girl that she's
now responsible for the safety and
survival of her entire race
nothing against you carrot but boy that
might be a little bit above her pay
grade huh they do say that she saw the
outside world but it was really just
wano and whole cake islands but then
again who am i to judge right the
character that i think is maybe the
hardest to see go and that has been
around as long as moment kinemon is of
course law who has been with the crew
since punk hazard and basically the
entire post-time skip saga both law and
kit are of course far from out of the
story much rather oda sensei actually
tries to make it a point here to set
them up as legit rivals to luffy
becoming pirate king but it still feels
like the end to an era if you know what
i mean and i think we all do know that
neither law nor kid in the end will
actually fight luffy for the one piece
but will stand by his side again in the
future i really love that law shared the
poneglyph with kit by the way which was
very unlike him but really shows the
respect that these three captains do
have for each other now kit also tells
us this mysterious story about going
after the man with the burning wound
that seems to be related to the last
poneglyph but isn't quite as nice as law
to share it with the others now i've
been really thinking about this and i
might have forgotten other characters
that do have a burning mark but the only
person that comes to mind really with
this in one piece is actually luffy's
brother sabo so could the
revolutionaries have something to do
with all this given that all three
captains are now officially leaving on
different routes i think it's fair to
assume that we're actually going to a
new island next as well and that of
course for the straw hats hopefully is
going to be elbaf where they might
finally meet shanks and if you want to
know what will happen when these two
finally meet you should really not miss
out on this video right here